okay pushed all the buttons we should
now be streaming hello everybody welcome
back to estriol coffee my name's Tony
Darnell you're watching the deep
astronomy channel on YouTube and it's
Thursday at 3 o'clock which means dr.
Bryan Keating is with us to talk about
some of the cool stuff that he's been
doing on his channel let me bring him up
here hey dr. Bryan Keating how are you
doing today
I am contact with you okay so well it's
good that I could do it with you as well
so you've been talking to lots of famous
people lately and not lately but for
quite a while and we're doing this in an
effort to let you guys know watching the
deep astronomy channel that you can
subscribe to dr. Brian Keyes channel so
please do that there is a link in the
description box there's also all the
things out of the they're full I linked
to the full interview that we're going
to introduce you to today
and so let's go ahead get started oh I
should let you know we're streaming on
Bryan's channel as well as my channel
and I'm looking at the chat on mine and
I assume that you are looking at the
chat on yours Bryan am i right ask those
questions and do things were what's
gonna happen is we're going to he's
gonna Bryan has to go after about 30
minutes I'll stick around after the fact
and ramble and chat with you guys a bit
more and talk about whatever you want so
let's wedding get started so Bryan tell
us what is new in the world of dr. Bryan
Keating land well it started off as you
remembered my pandemic podcast began
with the realization that all these
famous authors and brainiacs and
thinkers would be all cooped up over the
next few months to do this Cove in
nineteen emergency that were all
suffering through all over the world
literally mm-hmm and it started to make
me wonder if I could be of service to
them and also selfishly serve my own
interests and talking to these brilliant
minds and so I realized that I could do
so by leveraging my eager resources here
at UC San Diego to make a to make the
podcast more of a focus on books and
authors and thinkers and I was able to
reach out to some
luminaries who just so happened to be
making a lot of news and noise with new
ideas particularly in theoretical
physics where we've talked about Stephen
Wolfram who talked a little bit about
mario livio and some new ideas that
might be old again or old ideas that
must be new again
I don't know how to say it but the but
also thinking about how new really kind
of controversial ideas such as that of
Eric Weinstein and others might be of
interest to to my audience and he
specifically didn't mean and so I asked
through my you know he's a friend of
mine Eric Weinstein of that before but
he's the managing director of eager
Till's hedge fund basically this cow is
a venture capital fund called chick
that's his age but he's a he's a
mathematical he's trained at Harvard
give him that not it and he has some
very controversial theories about how
the universe could be organized in the
way that could demonstrate once and for
all
a true honest to goodness theory of
everything and I wanted to understand
that but also to kind of press him where
I feel like he needs to be challenged a
little bit and that was uh that was my
goal in our podcast interview which
scared about we could happen all right
we're gonna show a clip from that
interview here in just a minute but what
did you do what does he need to be
pressed on just what do you think what
do you what do you think he's uh he's
got so the main challenge is that he's
he's an outsider he's a very famous very
popular from his work online and really
being a pundit and a deep thinker but he
has almost nothing published and to the
extent that he does it's on a blog or on
his own podcast called portal which is
quite which is quite phenomenal but I
put a link as that in my description box
too so just so you know go ahead yeah so
so for us to really have a chance to
pour over ideas most businesses want to
see something published whether it's a
book whether it's a paper and more than
that they want to see a refereed
published journal article and I pointed
out that
you know in the case of Stephen Wolfram
the same exact charges were leveled at
him even though his ideas have been
published for a long time so I think the
main controversy is that he's he's kind
of criticizing the Academy of physics
which Wolfram does not what Weinstein is
basically claiming that there's been a
real dearth of progress for the last 50
years in theoretical physics and he
makes a connection between that and the
baby boomer generation and is kind of
pressing some nerves and some of that we
discussed in the clip but I think
they're cheery about the show well yeah
and I think he's right I mean really
let's think about it for a minute what
bigs new ideas have come out now I would
say more than just 50 years but let's go
back to you know a hundred years 92
1920s we had some really breakthrough
ideas but really since relativity what
have we what had what was what's what's
happened really we are everything what
happened since then has been confirming
things that Einstein predicted
gravitational waves being I think among
the latest of them but really what new
ideas are there string theory I mean I
think you're being a little harsher than
he is in setting their timescale for
kind of for the for the decline and fall
of the physics Empire writings actually
there are many people who dated exactly
to November of 1974 when something
called the JCI revolution took place oh
that's almost exactly 50 knots 40 what
forty six years ago that you know
revolution really in some people's minds
mark the end of progress in theoretical
particle physics and there were many
great proposals for things like string
theory supersymmetry etc but those have
not borne fruit and so he takes great
issue with those developments and feels
that those developments have dominated
the field like a guru like a like a
Svengali that's putting so much pressure
on young physicists to toe the line to
try to make a string theory work and
there's really no real productivity in
his mind he claims that this this is not
the way we should be doing science so
he's saying
with reference only to particle theory
and some people say he has a real point
but to answer your question there's many
developments since 1920s all I mean ok
so but I'm talking theoretically yes
we've discovered exoplanets we've
discovered we've imaged black holes
we've done a lot that's not my point my
point
what really new foundational physics has
been created all kinds like quantum
field theory the quark model these are
all things since you're brand-new these
are brand-new things that just
holography or teleportation we're
talking about obviously the perturbation
theory for cosmological observables dark
dark energy you know discoveries that
lead to new models that have connections
to things call in quantum field theory
so there's been a lot but but but don't
let them off the hook so easily because
it is and and you know my in theory it
has been relatively in the particle
theorists and now they're asking for
trillion you know billions of dollars
contributions a lot of trillions going
around these days but millions tens of
billions of dollars to build a new
advanced accelerator and there's no
promise that I will see anything and so
I think he has a point
yeah and I okay well let's go ahead and
play this clip and we maybe will come
back to this little topic but I know you
and I are chef at eco on the culture of
science and the way in which somebody's
some of these institutions need a little
bit of work but I'm you're right I'm a
little bit harsher I think on science
overall like I don't like just want to
see the money but let me let me let me
play this clip and all this and we'll
we'll talk later there is nothing more
important in my opinion for the
preservation of humanity than
theoretical physics yeah you think it's
actually culturally Susilo irrelevant to
this survival of a society if so how did
we do without it you know until the
1940s or so thank you Dirty's it's it's
necessary for the survival of humanity
for a couple of different reasons which
have to be pulled apart the first of
which is
theoretical physics is unique in the
sense that it's somehow trains the pure
mental facility and the gritty mental
facility to work together like nothing
else we've ever discovered I'm not
saying it's not impossible to duplicate
it again but even relative to
mathematicians who I could make an
argument might even be smarter in a
certain kind of technical sense the
power of the hybrid vigor of pure
cleanliness in pure grit produce
something where we never knew that the
human mind was capable of those flights
as we've seen in theoretical physics
so I really believe that if you wanted
to talk about you know the gym that
trains bodies to be at their peak well
for the mind that's theoretical physics
fundamental physics at best dojo right
it's Ludo Joe right so Wow okay I didn't
understand a lot of that grit what is
that what does he mean by that
oh hang on I'm sorry there's a sense
that in theoretical physics unlike
observational astronomy unlike
experimental physics that there tends to
be a dominant personality or cult of
personalities and the ones that he
speaks about most often are people like
Ed Witten or come run bhava at Harvard
and wouldn't it be nice to prevent study
these are the tastemakers
these are the these are the bringers of
the fire that hold the torch that
physicists are expected to cleave to
it's not like you can go to the
Institute for Advanced Study at
Princeton and say well I've got this
great idea as Eric does or you know some
some what's called geometric community
and I'm gonna transform the fundamentals
of no you're gonna be working underneath
leg back up the advisor as a postdoc or
as a graduate student and only when you
have gotten to a certain level of
success and originality creativity and
built your own brand then you can start
working for yourself and when he's
saying is that to survive
that takes this resiliency which i think
is calling i think that's what he needs
you know very few people have that right
you can't we're not in Stein's
and we're not Weinstein about where you
know it's very rare and I just realized
I it's a very close last name does that
a W okay yeah yeah right that's cool
okay so alright I get that now thank you
and so his statement about theoretical
physics being so necessary I think I
died I see where that's coming from but
but do you feel like do you agree with
that statement first of all that how
important theoretical physics is I
believe that physics in general is
incredibly important I think that we as
he calls us he calls the theoretical
physics community SEAL Team six of the
mine so I actually know people on the
SEAL team say so they're very brilliant
I don't want to you know say that
they're not as intellectually capable as
any physicist I know but he's basically
making the point that you know that we
are these problem solvers that have
really revealed with the closest and the
most deep attributes to truth that could
possibly exist I also broaden that to
experimentalist because I think actually
experimentalists are the ones that are
capable of of proving or disproving that
these models that are thought up by
theorists are actually correct so I
point to an event that happened in 2016
you remember after the Higgs boson was
announced that all these people got
really excited about this new signal
that came up and it had like one in a
million chance of being right by chance
and it was called the die photon and it
had these weird properties maybe could
be Dark Matter maybe yeah anyway there
are 500 Papers written in the span of
about six months and then it went away
completely and then you don't even hear
about it anymore and so I think it's
easy in some sense to create a theory to
come up with a theory that explains
things just as week yesterday in fact I
talked to a good friend of mine a B here
reg he's a professor at Chicago she
doesn't have a bug but they just did a
podcast about this result that you might
have seen
new york post that this experiment in
antarctica saw evidence for parallel
universes where time goes backwards and
it was whose soul were blown nonsense
the coal that i had to talk to somebody
who actually built the experiments and
if I just talk to theorists they will
cherry pick it right so that's what
happened with his die photon and I think
this happens much more commonly in
theoretical physics than anything so
sorry my truck is ready to be picked up
so the the the theoretical underpinnings
then of how okay let me back up a little
bit so this idea of how we do physics
how we do science tends to be we start
at this mind mindful level of you know
this this level of creativity and
intelligence and imagination and the
mind works out these theories right
that's where they begin in some in a
human mind or in a group of human minds
but generally it tends to be one person
and then from that theories are
developed and and then this would be a
foundation for how physics has done do
you think that we have and so I've
always felt like physics especially and
astrophysics is a sub general sub-genre
of that have plenty of theorists we have
plenty of theories what we need more of
is observation and experiment and so
what what what do you think what would
you say to that and yeah and what do you
think Eric would say yeah man I could
find a coffee I could find a parking
space at the Institute so yeah
cappuccino
I do obviously agree with you I think
experiment is the true arbiter right
wrong and Leasing science however these
experiments are victims of their own
success
look we've predicted things we've
serendipitously observe things now we
picked all the low-hanging fruit and the
question is you know what kind of tree
only can survive with it as these really
high altitude fruit that require
billions of dollars hundreds of people
there's just and I talked with that with
another author today Sabine Hassan
father in or wrote a book called lost
map that help will talk about income
police and that pieces of that is that
we shouldn't spend any more money and
big experiments because there's no
theoretical motivation for them to
discover say a new higgs particle or
something beyond what we already know
about and maybe in this desert
this discovery desert for a long time so
she is actually argued against and she's
a fitness issues arguing against
building its bones because their cost to
not be just the [ __ ] Wow I guess I
hadn't thought about that I mean I was a
little bit surprised to learn very
recently and one of the members of my
chat pointed it out on a Twitter stream
I did that the Large Hadron Collider
only costs four point seven billion
dollars to make it is I didn't believe
it either look it up it's true now i
think i think it's well first of all you
always have to double every well okay
that's what that's what wikipedia says
it cost right so I mean if it's wrong
it's wrong but I was shocked by that too
because I remember when Texas was
getting the superconducting
supercollider Congress threw away five
billion dollars before they cancelled it
right it was about of that level when
they had already cancelled it so I was
shocked to hear that too but I did I
looked it up and that's what it said it
cost and of course DST is not it is nine
billion I don't know if that was
adjusted for yeah are you seeing that I
know I know but what else we got right
yeah that was from 2012 right after the
discovery of the Higgs and so I I had
trouble with it too but I couldn't say
anything about it because there was the
number I'm like well okay I
No and JWST by comparisons nine so as
twice as much and so you're like so
you're saying the cost of science the
cost of these these experimental
verifications of the theories are
getting what the return on investment is
not good enough I mean how how would you
say it's just too expensive on what
again all is later on what price do you
put knowledge I mean that sign so I
guess the question that Eric is that
again these aren't my no I understand
message service he would say something
like you know think of how many postdocs
you could find graduate students you
could fund for the cost of the
next-generation Collider which is you
know thirty billion dollars and that's
just to build where there's according to
Savini there's no you know target
there's no experimental threshold all
right so I think a different tax when
there is a lower limit so in science you
often have an upper limit in other words
the signal can be no bigger than this or
else we would have detected it and
that's where we are now with with the
search for gravitational waves from
inflation the SIRT the signal could be
no smoke no larger than a certain amount
which we then translate into a
constraints on the theory of inflation
and whether or not that could be true
next the thing is is there a lower limit
in other words is it possible for the
signal to be any smaller or is that
forbidden so take neutrinos for example
neutrinos are known to have a maximum
mass that can't be bigger than a certain
amount but they also are known to have a
lower limit that can't be smaller there
and that range is getting tighter and
tighter from the high end that's coming
in from the low end that's coming in and
we're eventually going to detect what
the NASA team neutrino is so I would say
funding search - that has a legitimate
chance to say detect the masses of the
neutrinos for the first time then I
think it's I think that's incredibly
worthy if you say we're gonna build an
experiment to maybe discover something
that we weren't expecting and I've heard
scientists tell me us we're gonna build
a huge telescope because who knows what
we'll find when Galileo turned his
telescope to the sky he didn't know what
he was looking for I don't think that's
a good justification today in an
infinite budget world that's one
similarly with a particle
we don't know if we don't have a good
target where we know the signal can't be
smaller than something I worry about
funding that as well and but I'm not an
expert in the probability assignment of
how likely it is to find supersymmetry I
mean she claims things like and heat and
Erik claims things like string theory
and supersymmetry are not only not
possible to be proven in other words are
not falsifiable but they're also not
possible to really you know continue in
other words you've seen everything that
could possibly be of interest and so now
you're just kind of justifying this
pursuit according to them I don't you
know I'm not an expert in these fields
but Erik's idea is a little bit deep we
were in that we really we should
actually charge people for physics so
it's very controversial so things that
physicists have built discovered
theorized that are used right now as
we're talking the Internet HTTP protocol
was developed at CERN you know long
before the LHC if we charge you know a
penny per instruction or website view
that he claims would be a way to recoup
the debt that society owes the physicist
he actually said that pay a back man
okay well I gotta lie we're running out
of time and I have a question for you
but before I ask it I'm like okay well
Simon farmer who by the way is the one
that he was right he's the one that
pointed out to me at the cost of ELAC on
a twitch stream he did us he's asking
you dr. Keating just as experiments have
grown quite expensive isn't it possible
that theories that theories have grown
too complex for a single mind and Eric
is just looking for help that's very
interesting
so rather than experiment is that you
can't do an experiment anymore with just
the lone genius working in our lab or
whatever right you really can't do that
anymore I think that what we want - well
the difference in theory is there is
still that mindset that you could be
Paul Dirac Richard Fineman Galileo
Einstein you know choose your favorite
hero and you'll have all this glory and
eventually win a Nobel Prize right
that's part of the thesis of my book
that the Nobel Prize is leaving
physicists astray because it's really
perpetuating this notion of history
that's incorrectly or trade by the
victors of you know whoever wins another
a prize that's the way science is
actually constructed so I think I think
it's it's it's there are some extremely
bright people in the world and even
people like like Ed Witten or Eric
Weinstein who feel inadequate maybe
because they're not trained as
physicists or train is not petitions in
this case he will look to somebody
likely and he will say you know this is
one of the greatest minds who's ever
lived
and and Eric is one of the greatest I
mean he's incredibly brilliant whether
you like him dislike him disagree he can
talk about anything from the
organizational structure of some
university in the 1960s in Europe and
then he could talk about like politics
you know between two different factions
of you know Andrew yang and Bernice and
it's just unbelievable how how versatile
he is intellectually but just speaking
and physics terms I do hear the
complaint and I resonate with that that
he has yet to publish anything in a
format that is remotely accessible to
the average person I'm gonna give you
guys a link to this really cool physics
project thing that he's working on on
his website called the wall and he's
it's a it's a representation of
something that's that's carved
physically into the walls of the Symons
Institute for geometry State University
of New York at Stony Brook where I was
born and I grew up hmm and I will put
that in the chat right now and this wall
that Eric's talking about is is really
representing the culmination the the
amazing contributions of all of all of
knowledge and it's on my channel I don't
know if it's going to your channel too
yeah I think so I just put it there
people can click on it so if you clicked
on it it shows this wall and you can
click on the different equations in the
wall and this is really you know a
beautiful kind of representation of the
advanced creations of all of human
civilization and I think it's quite
wonderful the question is yeah can any
one person understand that yeah course I
mean I can get about halfway down this
list and I'm just a simple
experimentalist now can I make new
contributions to it I don't think so
but I can work to say look at the middle
equation of the Dirac equation like this
weird capital T with a strike through it
are you looking at this Tony no I'm not
it because I didn't it didn't come
through I like yeah so I have too many
other words
yeah but thingy but the important thing
is you've got this amazing creation and
an a human mind can not only carve it
into the wall but human mind can
understand it question is can you
contribute something new that's missing
from this law that's a deeper question
and you know you can't order up
serendipitous discoveries they come when
they come and by nature these
discoveries most of them are
serendipitous like we didn't expect from
the get-go
that the universe would manifest grab
funding via curvature of space-time or
else
Isaac Newton whose laws up there would
have had a very different construction
of his law okay well I want to ask you
about since when do you think it's
possible with single people yeah
oh okay so uh I want to talk about
theory of everything since that's in the
title of this hangout and I'm sure you
you oh you just went away okay so he he
just left my hangout no I don't have
we're not on a zoom meeting I've got him
in my Wirecast program as a guest and so
he can't share a screen here and he just
dropped out so hopefully he'll he'll
come back in in just a minute I would
like to comment though
let me just read Simon's comment might
take away from your interview with Eric
was that he acknowledges there really is
an elite within the physics community
and that they'd be better off looking at
his theory then string theory it yeah it
might be a certain sort of sour grapes
there
in some respect but I want to go I want
to talk about just a little bit I want
to comment on the serendipitous nature
of science that's really we tend to
gloss over that this this idea that you
know the way in which science is
advanced is advancing if you think about
it it's not really based on science
itself is it how do these theories get
generated in the first place
do they come from any sort of rational
world sometimes sure by looking at the
world we can make hypotheses and we can
and we can build up theories based on
what we see around the world but a lot
of it is based on creativity and a lot
of it is based on and you know just just
imagination and that it's very these are
very non-scientific things and I bring
that up because you know we the science
depends on things that are not
necessarily scientific for its success
and this in these theories are an
example what I was going to ask Brian
was about this idea as if he really it
does there have to be a theory of
everything does the entire does
everything we know about the universe
have to be distilled into an t-shirt
equation right as an equation that will
fit on a t-shirt you know do we do it is
this a real goal for physics does that
mean it's something that hue that in our
human minds we are predisposed to
thinking would be nice you know it's
like it's it's aesthetically pleasing to
the human mind but there's no there's no
requirement I think that there be a
theory of everything one theory from
which everything sprouts may not be the
way the universe is and I've always been
confused by this need this drive to link
relativity to quantum mechanics or
things like that I I think that all of
these laws are valid and they work in ER
in a regime in which they're relevant
right quantum mechanics is in a certain
works in a certain regime Newtonian
mechanics is it is relevant in a certain
regime and then up to where it's not
really very accurate relativity takes
over and does a very wonderful job I
have been wondering
lately about this idea of what's past
relativity
there must be something more beyond
relativity that before we get to a
theory of everything and I'm I so
nothing's changed the link is the same
Brian
let me see he's probably emailed me no
let me just say what happens when you
click on the link you're watching me
send emails isn't this fun
who says the internet isn't the best
ever okay
anyway he should be able to just jump
right back in nothing's changed I don't
know how he got got disconnected
okay well I'm keeping a lookout for him
and CP jumps back in sorry Brian don't
know what happened there you got thrown
out and just as I was about to ask my
question so jr. balls is commenting I
have listened to a lot of Eric and he
had some real issues with in the
academic world himself which is why he
sat on his work for so long
add to that the problems his brother had
it evergreen dot dot okay Simon wants to
know I really actually really I'd like
to know your opinion on what he said
about building bigger telescopes I think
we'll we know we'll see new things with
bigger telescopes yeah that's very true
salty my two cents I think science
should be done with a worldwide network
not and not only for science a network
should be able to connect to an other
networks as they need lone-wolf is just
slow yes
but I actually think I've got a point
here
if this this business of lack of
progress yes okay so Brian says yeah
we've had some we've had some stuff
happen since the 70s or the last 50
years you know there was been a few
breakthroughs here and there in physics
but they aren't next level stuff right I
mean what happened in the early 20th
century was just you know it was a
watershed of new discoveries so I'm I'm
very disappointed that that hasn't
really continued much and I blame a lot
of it on the culture of science right
this idea that this good ol boy network
of whoo you know and the theories that
are currently in favor are the ones that
are gonna get listened to at the expense
of all these other theories and then
these really expensive experiments need
to be built in order to prove these
theories really hamper science and I
just wonder I think that I think science
has become a lot less productive from a
theoretical standpoint then it has from
an experimental standpoint it has boomed
experimentally technology has gone to a
place where we can now see things we
could never hope to see before and it
has cost a lot of money to do that for
sure gravitational waves we looked for
decades before we finally saw them the
same with the finding the Higgs boson we
built the this big built multi-billion
dollar super collider to do it and we
saw it finally and now the James Webb
Space Telescope is going to be launched
at nine billion dollars W first or the
Nancy Grace Roman Space Telescope is
going to be done I can't believe I
remembered that I'm really proud of
myself it's gonna be launched it
probably half that cost who knows really
what's gonna cost when it finally
launches but all these telescopes for
talking multibillion-dollar
efforts here and so science is getting
very expensive and is it still a good
value it's a question I think that you
should ask to me if you ask me of course
it's a good value always science is a
good value especially just because of
you know how successful that's been on
our understanding of the universe
and I do think that we need a theory
that goes past relativity because we
need to explain singularities right we
the singularities that exist in our
universe black holes in the Big Bang
those kinds of singularities are a
problem for our current physical
framework and we have to have answers
for these you know we can't have an
event horizon beyond which our physics
stops working there's something
fundamentally missing there that we need
to figure out right there's got to be a
theory that we can plug in that says oh
yeah black holes or areas where light
doesn't can't get out and if you go into
one then we have to invoke this new
theory that is superseding or on top of
or in addition to relativity that does
explain the things relativity can and my
thinking goes like this and I've done
this on Twitch several times but you
know Copernicus was right up to a point
about you know the solar system and
along comes Kepler and Newton and they
flesh out the the framework a little bit
more they're a little bit more right
than Copernicus and Galileo were and now
we've got a bigger more accurate
framework and then but that only worked
up to a certain point beyond which we
needed relativity to kick in and tell us
what's going on in the universe and then
of course there was the very small stuff
which quantum mechanics took care of and
does a decent job I don't see this need
to connect the two but let you know I'm
not very smart compared to some of these
other people who do think that so I'll
defer to them but relativity has holes
in it too and not the least of which are
these singularities relativity can't
explain them we it has nothing to say
past the event horizons so we need
something to invoke that does fix it and
so we are at best incomplete in our
understanding of the universe for sure
but whether we're ever gonna get a
theory of everything especially one that
fits on a t-shirt I just don't I just
don't see the need for it I don't I'm
not driven for that I'm driven for to
this idea of understanding what we you
know filling in the holes of things that
we don't understand and we have a lot of
holes we're nowhere - done by any
stretch of the imagination so let's see
Raj is hey Raj NASA has an idea of
building a telescope and one of the
craters on the moon yes good idea let's
do it
oh I think he just emailed me let's see
do do do you know I don't see his email
oh yeah there it is it says waiting to
be let in oh there you are okay there
you are so now I see you appearing hold
tight and I shall add you in ah let's
see
stand by
sorry I've got to do this quickly
all right are you there Bryan are you
there hello I hear you yep I can hear
you
alright there you go I I just I just I
just fixed sorry about that don't know
what happened but you're back now and so
glad you're back I hope you still got
some time I know we've gone past five
more minutes okay like my theory my
question to you about theory of
everything I was just making this point
that I don't see why we need to make
this big theory of everything that
connects say relativity to quantum
mechanics and have this real nice
t-shirt sized equation that we can say
describes everything but do do you feel
that way do you do you feel like that
that there is a theory that will connect
all of the current theories that don't
connect and how important is that
do you or do you think it's something
else answer it and issue you know it's
like they say you know the physics needs
physicists to come up with theories of
everything the way that birds need
ornithology mythologist you know it's
like do we need it doesn't is it
important what would it do so you can
arguably make the case that Newton's
theory was certainly much more simple
than Aristotle's theory of motion or
even Galileo's I was just making that
point and then actually is all the math
you need to get to the moon yeah so so
do we need it no I don't think we need
any of it I think we benefit from it I
think it's a aspect of culture of the
human mind
that is insatiable that we were
continuing to look for it and why is it
a theory of everything so the reason
that happens is that we we know that
there are four forces of nature we know
that there aren't so-called hidden
variables or strange aspects of quantum
mechanics that are inaccessible to our
experiments you know we know that the
properties that we know about are you
know represent the sum total of things
that at least can interact with the
physical world and when we write down a
single equation we can actually write
down a single equation already and we
can even write down a similar equation
that encapsulates all of physical
theories plus gravity as long as gravity
is classical in other words you can
write down all of quantum mechanics and
you can write down all of classical
gravity and you can marry those two
together the problem is when you try to
go to quantum gravitational systems if
indeed gravity is quantum quantum
quantized effect then you would have a
theory of everything like that is what
would constitute a theory of everything
okay and because of our need to kind of
make I call it half like people want to
simplify and have a shortcut you know
it's like lose weight you know I'll show
you this one weird trick you know that
bypasses all the 40 years plus of of
eating them no we want a one simple
trick that fits on the wall on the
t-shirt on the whatever but that's a
hack right why do you need that you
don't actually sit there and in the end
of the day and say I'm going to turn on
my computer let me apply with the rocket
confirmed mass into energy by using the
speed of light exactly so I think it's
part of the human mind just like you
know right in the Great American Novel
is there such a thing now of course not
yeah it doesn't stop people and I think
it's a good graph as long as it's done
in moderation frankly I'll say let's
fund a billion people to keep doing this
there has to be a limit actually one of
my friends who's a phenomenally
accomplished astronomer I won't say his
name but but he basically thinks we have
too many postdoctoral
you know fellowships like we're actually
encouraging people to go into a field
where there's no terminal point and even
today I was talking to Sabine
Hasenpfeffer who's that very
accomplished scientist and their best
selling off their common all these
things about tens of hundreds of
thousands of fans her YouTube channels
phenomenal and we should talk about her
in about two weeks G doesn't have a
permanent job she doesn't work in the
Orthodox mainstream of her field and you
know and I think she's it's not for lack
of knowledge she understands as well as
anybody so do we have an obligation to
maybe you know try to channel more
people into experimental physics I would
like that personally come and and we
have an obligation to fund really hard
high-risk high-reward value the reason
that Eric said we should charge every
penny for semiconductor you know because
semiconductors are invented by the
theoretical physicist and
experimentalist as well is because he
wants the fun experiment theoretical
physics but you can say that and I can
agree with you but how do you actually
get it done I don't think anyone's gonna
pay a tax on each email and in order I
think that would be good so I said no
it's led to the same way LEDs were solid
state yeah thanks guy right so yeah
lasers yeah majors radar the list of
physics accomplishments is tremendous
all right you know the question is how
do we do that how do we get more
theoretical blood into the field that is
not the question I think I think some of
it is maybe lessening the prestige of
these prizes like the breakthrough prize
that Nobel Prize let's take that money
and make 20 different postdoc
fellowships and give tenure you know
have more tenure-track faculty in the
theoretical sciences I think that that's
interesting things to pursue and and now
I don't know if you saw this but the
National Science Foundation they're
proposing they'll include technology and
so it'll be perhaps even less connected
to the pure basic scientific research
that I that I do yeah I just worry that
that working for a theory of everything
as a goal is a little bit of a wasted
energy because I think if there is in
fact a theory of everything that is the
truth of the universe that it will come
out in whatever path we end up taking to
get there so while we ran
during other mysteries or we're not
being so focused on trying to find a
theory that explained that links gravity
and a quantum level or whatever that
we're looking at these other ideas that
we're trying to figure out in the
universe that we're gonna get there
anyway if it really is one theory that
does everything then we're gonna find it
inevitably just by doing honest
investigations into the universe so I
just worry that it's wasted every well
this doesn't come this doesn't come you
know connect and so but maybe it's
valuable in another way that's my only
real worry about this and I and Adam
synergy just made a comment of does
physics have to be beautiful I mean
that's a really valid quite it does it
have to end up being elegant you know or
you know fit on a t-shirt so um these
are all things I worried might be a bit
of a distraction and and it sounds like
you know we that you think that it's
it's getting there
yes is worthwhile we should be looking
for this theory of of everything and
while we go along it sounds like yeah I
think I think you're Adam you like this
podcast I do listen sabine because she
may that's the name of her book lost in
math how mathematics and beauty lead
physics astray and she claims that
fascination obsession with beauty and
symmetry and so forth and reduction to
these elegant universe type statements
and she's really a vocal opponent of
people like Brian green and you know
kind of flower Leland maybe that Sean
Carroll text like that right so I want
to see what your audience would like to
see more so I've had some hopes to so
I'm gonna have a second part with Erik
people are interested in that that's
gonna come out hopefully on Father's Day
Sunday we did a special episode of
Sascha Segan for Mother's Day so I know
about his fatherhood and also being a
scientist mentor some of his
controversial statements about places
like Harvard and mentors in this field
that'll launch on Father's Day so stay
tuned for that he actually asked me well
what about getting you know sean carroll
and stephen wolfram and eric i'm on my
podcast at the same time i've got all
three of them on what do people think
about
yeah dude no they don't even ask they're
all gonna say yes to that that would be
amazing
yeah that would be if you do that do
that that would be an outstanding panel
to have on a as a discussion so yeah
well what you guys can do out there is
is kind of convinced I'm speaking soon
after their podcast yeah so please chat
with them and tell them that's what we
guys want you guys want a three-way calm
for weight conversation on my podcast
with Wolfram Weinstein and Carole and
and anyone else you can think about he's
doing crazy times maybe it maybe it can
happen soon crazy yeah well I don't get
to warn you gotta go okay yeah all right
I just kneel you I just get to Neil's
question he's got do you think that of a
I will solve anything for soon in
physics what about the role of
artificial intelligence in physics and
then I'll let you go so I'm hoping to
have on a friend of mine max tegmark
he's he's kind of the opposite side of
Sabine where he's you know purely has
this mathematical universe that would be
you know really startling ly opposed by
people like Sabine basically everything
is just pure mathematics and every every
atom every electron is the same as any
other atom electron it's all just a
numerical representation of reality so
he wrote another book called life 3.0
that I reviewed in physics today so I'll
put a link to that in the notes right
now but that that aren't that well
really it states you know the case is
trying to come up with them what's we
called the AI physicist and the a they
are physicists will you know learn about
like it will discover Newton's laws for
example by looking at they and and he's
shown that it will happen or certain
things in thermodynamics the palm is it
may only be able to say things about
things we already know about and so I
would like to have him on the podcast to
talk about that exact same question good
point what would a AI physicist - that's
novel
Neil I think that's what you're getting
at what a novel creation or is that
unique to the human mind
I think that's a fascinating that is
that is a that is that would be a
fascinating question for sure because I
was
trying to make the point that science
depends a lot on things like creativity
and imagination to progress and so it
would be if if an AI can do this work
without any of those things than there
goes my theory right there so that that
would be an outstanding discussion to
hear so okay Brian thank you and I gotta
go don't forget to hit in stream on my
channel because i'm about to ramble and
so and so you I don't want that on your
channel so thanks I'll see you next week
right maybe right no right okay yeah
we'll see you next week all right talk
to you later bye bye okay all right so I
think let me just look at